is there any is a car on rental cars and
vehicles the company's own for moving
produce as far as possessing vehicular
which are given under the same view is
used as houses on rent in the same thing
so majority of the scholars say that if
it's like a union but no zakat is they
on that vehicle
fine if it's a taxi driver who is a poor
person who has one taxi and e-learning
is just a few hundred dollars a month or
a few thousand rupees a month but
natural if you pay the hard on the cost
of the vehicle on the taxi will be too
much for it so I agree that there should
be no zakat on the cost of the vehicle
but on the other hand if you have a
person who owns a fleet of cars maybe a
thousand cars you know we have hard sand
is big the company who owned thousands
of cars now for them that itself becomes
an asset no if they give on rent they
can't keep on buying every few months
hundreds and thousands of cars so I
believe that if it's a fleet of cars and
if it is you know undrained then the
cost price the depreciated cost price
don't date the cost at which you bought
the car but take the depreciated cost
every I keep on taking on depreciation
but give it at that value you give to
enough percent a heart that will be
preferable I agree more with those same
group of scholars
Shekhar davi kidney Aki Technol Arabi
sheikh abu surah abdul rehman
al hasan and all these people souls